Renowned for steep ski movie worthy lines and epic views of the Swiss Alps,...
...Verbier is a paradise for adventurous skiers and riders.
Oh, and cheese lovers.
As the world's top freeride destination,...
...Verbier has tremendous skiing and I couldn't wait to explore it.
I was lucky enough to be guided around by local pro snowboarder Geraldine Fasnacht.
To access the best lines, we did a lot of hiking to secret stashes...
...and it was 100% worth the effort.
Now, let's talk about the views.
The Swiss Alps are mind-blowing...
...and Verbier provides incredible opportunities to take it all in.
For the best views,...
...it's key to take the tram to the ski area's 10,918-foot summit, Mont Fort.
From here, you can see the backside of the legendary Matterhorn...
...and even as far as Mont Blanc.
On top of skiing and the views,...
...this wouldn't be Switzerland if we didn't talk about the cheese.
Alpine fair classics like fondue and raclette originated in the Swiss Alps...
...so you can bet I was swimming in cheese after a big day of skiing in Verbier.
Definitely check out Le Caveau, a popular raclette joint in the heart of the village.
The owner and cheesemakers have many stories to tell...
...and it's a great experience for those looking to enjoy more Swiss culture.